poll number one is what percent of hello
aliens evolved from biological species
with two main genders and uh
you know the the popular vote is above
80 percent so most of them have two
genders what do you think about that
i'll ask you about some of these because
it's so interesting it's such an
interesting question it is a fun set of
questions yes i like one set of
questions so the genders as we look
through evolutionary history uh what's
the usefulness of that as opposed to
having just one or like millions
so there's a question in evolution of
life on earth there are very few species
that have more than two genders there
are some but there are they aren't very
many
but there's an enormous number of
species that do have two genders much
more than one
and so there's a literature on
why did multiple genders evolve and
that's sort of what's the point of
having males and females versus
hermaphrodites um so most plants are
mafridis that is they have there they
they would mate male female but each
plant can be either role
and then most animals have chosen to
split into males and females
and then they're differentiating the two
genders and you know there's an
interesting set of questions about why
that happens because you can do
selection
you basically have um
like one gender competes
for the affection of other and there's
sexual
partnership that creates the offspring
so there's sexual selection it's nice to
have
a like a
to a party it's nice to have dance
partners and then you get each one get
to choose based on certain
characteristics and that's an efficient
mechanism for adapting to the
environment being successfully adapted
to the environment
it does look like there's an advantage
in if you have males then the males can
take higher variance and so there can be
stronger selection among the males in
terms of weeding out genetic mutations
because the males have higher variance
in their mating success
you